please donate to give directly the
non-profit letting you send cash
directly to the world's poorest families
when you donate to give directly.org
Pacman a generous donor will match your
donations up to fifteen thousand dollars
makes a perfect holiday gift help us
reach fifteen thousand dollars by the
end of the year using the link below
I cannot tell you how sick of and
disgusted by this new incoming
Republican Congressman George Santos I
am
um this is the guy who earlier in the
week I told you that the openly gay
Jewish Republican who had been elected
lied about his employment history
and he lied about his educational
history
and he lied that four of his employees
were victims in the Pulse Nightclub
shooting
and that it was lie after lie after lie
and then after that we learned okay well
he lied about all of those things but he
is Jewish right it appears that he lied
about being Jewish as well
okay I said at least he really is gay
and I said it jokingly because of course
he is
and it has now been revealed that three
years ago
he was married to a woman now
you could be gay
and have been married to a woman we know
of situations that do too stigma or
family shame or for whatever reason that
a member of the LGBT community might
live in a way that is different than
their true feelings and maybe that's the
case with this guy but he hid the fact
that he had been married to a woman and
divorced her as recently as just a
couple years ago and he lied about
everything else so what are we to
believe and it is just stunning openly
gay Congressman elect George Santos
didn't disclose divorce with woman
writes Roger sullenberger for The Daily
Beast Santos ran his campaign as an
openly gay Republican since he was
elected a number of key biographical
details have started to crumble here is
the latest one
and it is yet another one of these cases
where we find out that the truth appears
to be very different from the story that
he told as the article reads and in the
this is accurate Santos who claims he
has quote never experienced
discrimination in the Republican Party
broke barriers when he became the first
openly gay non-incumbent Republican
candidate elected to congress but
according to court records obtained by
The Daily Beast Santos appeared to be
the subject of a previously
unacknowledged September 2019 divorce
almost September almost 2020 rather with
a woman in Queens County New York the
divorce which Santos has not discussed
publicly adds new uncertainty to his
already shaky biographical and political
claims I am openly gay have never had an
issue with my sexual identity in the
past decade and I can tell you and
assure you I will always be an advocate
for lgbtq folks now maybe he's bisexual
he didn't say that
um maybe there's some other explanation
but when you've lied about everything it
starts to become very very difficult to
believe that we also have additional new
information about the stories related to
his supposed Jewish ancestry CNN
reporting incoming congressman's claim
his grandparents fled the Holocaust
contradicted by genealogy records and as
I said earlier this week it's not Stolen
Valor we apply that to the military but
it is taking it is appropriating a story
that includes trauma and oppression and
discrimination that your family did not
suffer and making it your own and it's
disgusting
um stack and Kaczynski right for CNN
claims by George Santos that his
grandparents quote survived the
Holocaust as Ukrainian Jewish refugees
from Belgium who changed their surname
to survive are contradicted by sources
reviewed by CNN's k-file including
family trees compiled by genealogy
websites records on Jewish refugees and
interviews with multiple genealogists
Santos who has called himself half
Jewish and a Latino Jew folks I'm
actually a Latino Jew okay
has claimed his maternal grandfather was
originally from Ukraine
and fled to Brazil to escape Nazism
sounds like my family history to
Argentina except fake in another telling
the New York Republican said his
grandparents converted to Catholicism
during the rise of Nazism in Belgium
after fleeing Stalin in another telling
he claimed his family changed their name
to survive Nazism anyway no proof of
those claims it all appears to be
completely and totally made up
so
there's a lot of important things here
I don't want to Discount the possibility
that for whatever reason
it happens that gay people marry they
get in a heterosexual marriage and
there's all sorts of different reasons
and if that's what happened but he lied
about everything else well then we can
still talk about all those other things
but
this guy it's hard to find a more
dishonest person than George Santos
based on what we've seen and learned so
far and so I believe everything has to
be under the microscope now does it
matter he was voted by the people to
become a congressman and he is
congressman-elect as I said earlier this
week in any normal job not a job where
you're elected
you would be fired for misstating so
much about your history now you wouldn't
declare your sexual orientation as part
of a normal job interview so that's kind
of off the table
I don't know that if you tell your
employer you're Jewish and you're not I
don't know about that having
consequences but your resume where you
worked where you got your your degree
these are things where if it turned out
you falsified it you would be fired
essentially in just about every job and
so what happens next what happens next
with this guy probably nothing quite
frankly but a disgusting turn of events
and what started with he may have
um misstated or exaggerated his work
history and his role as what was it like
an asset manager or something
it seems his entire background is
completely and totally fake I'm gonna
now take another step back it does seem
this guy is from the species Homo
sapiens that appears to be true he
claims to be human he presents as human
I believe he is actually human maybe
that's the next thing that will be
proven wrong
Donald Trump is demanding reinstatement
and suggesting the government be
overthrown this is what happens when you
try to lead an Insurrection it fails and
you suffer no real consequences what do
you expect to see happen
Newsweek reports Donald Trump demands
reinstatement suggests overthrowing
government
this all uh happened of course on Donald
Trump's uh platform truth social which I
know you're familiar with I won't even
bother playing the clip in the midst of
a crucial week for the former president
over his role in January 6 Capital
attack and his tax returns Trump doubled
down on his big lie the debunked
conspiracy that the 2020 presidential
election was stolen Trump posting to
truth social quote the FBI and Twitter
colluded to elect Joe Biden now that's a
lie
Jesse Waters quoting Jesse Waters in
other words the 2020 presidential
election was rigged it was not and
stolen
it was not Trump says it all began a
long time ago they spied on my campaign
they did not I will remind you the claim
about spying on my campaign is the
following
during the 2016 presidential campaign
Trump and people around him were in
touch with so many targets of law
enforcement investigations who were
under surveillance that when the Trump
people would get on the phone with the
targets of law enforcement they would be
surveilled incidentally because they
were in touch with so many suspicious
people Trump's campaign was not being
spied on Trump's campaign was so sketchy
and it was in touch with so many uh uh
believed to be criminals that they were
incidentally surveilled okay let's go
back to the truth here uh spite on my
campaign not true and tried to rig the
2016 election but failed that is a lie
remember our government is doing this
not a person or party what should be
done about such a terrible thing or
should we let someone who was elected by
cheating and fraud
stay in office and continue to destroy
our country understand what he's saying
there
he's saying based on his
misunderstanding and lies about what
happened
Joe Biden shouldn't be allowed to stay
in office now there is no constitutional
or legal basis for that so all that is
left is exactly the type of violent
government overthrow and coup that
Donald Trump attempted to pull off in
2020 but thankfully failed and one of
the things that I hope we have learned
at this point is that the the argument
over he's deluded or he believes it he's
joking or he's positioning and it's a
grift and it's Financial or whatever it
doesn't matter in the end what we
believe about the individual that is
making the claims what matters is what
do their followers ultimately believe
and what we learned in January of 2021
is that the followers believed it enough
that hundreds of them nearly a thousand
maybe the real number is over a thousand
we just don't have the full number yet
700 or so
uh committed specific crimes for the
allegedly committed specific crimes for
which they're being charged and many
have already been adjudicated and
thousands and thousands more were
willing to add this add themselves to a
mob uh that was filled with hundreds of
specific law Breakers so whether Trump
believed it or he didn't or he wanted to
instigate or he wanted to use it as a
tool to raise money it really doesn't
matter it's sort of like yesterday we
talked about oh Sean Hannity under oath
said he didn't believe any of Trump's
claims fine he didn't believe him so
it's actually almost worse knowingly he
repeated incorrect statements that fed
the machine that ultimately led to the
January 6 riots and I go back to what I
said at the beginning
if you're never held accountable
if you don't suffer any consequences why
on Earth would you change your behavior
so Trump is back talking again about the
removal of Biden the overthrow of the
government and the reinstatement of
himself now it's not going to happen the
way he could get himself reinstated is
by winning in November of 2024 and let's
hope that does not happen but unless
there are real consequences for these
people and maybe we will soon know
whether there will be for Trump
why would they ever stop doing the same
stuff over and over again they wouldn't
and so we're uh fomenting this very
thing happening again via that lack of
consequences scary and disgusting stuff
over this holiday season please remember
how many families around the world are
living in extreme poverty our partner
give directly is the non-profit letting
you send cash directly to the world's
poorest households help the David
packman show reach our goal of fifteen
thousand dollars by the end of the year
at give directly.org Pacman a generous
give directly donor will match all
donations up to fifteen thousand dollars
to help us hit that goal so your
donation can have double the impact
giving in someone's name is a great last
minute holiday gift when organizations
give cash to families like this about 90
cents on the dollar get to the recipient
versus sometimes as little as 50 cents
on the dollar in terms of relative
impact with many other programs that's
why I reached out to give directly about
doing this with us give directly is how
you know every dollar you donate is
going to good use giving even a few
dollars can have a massive impact for
someone living on a dollar or two a day
help us reach fifteen thousand dollars
by December Thirty One and your donation
will be doubled go to give directly.org
Pacman the link is down below the David
packman show is an audience supported
program we have the membership program
you can sign up at joinpakman.com we do
an extra show every day for our members
called the bonus show we also provide a
commercial free audio and video stream
of the show every single day to our
members you can get the show hours
before everybody else when you sign up
at joinpakman.com and with no
commercials very very exciting we also
invite our members to members only Town
Halls where you can talk to me but only
you sign up at joinpakman.com you can
use the coupon code 24 starts now if you
would like if you would like let's hear
from some people in the audience we take
calls via Discord at davidpackman.com
Discord
um make sure that you set your nickname
in the waiting Lobby to your name and
where you're calling from those are the
rules nicknames Etc are not welcome
let's go first to Tyrone from Ohio
Tyrone welcome what's on your mind today
Tyrone welcome what is on your mind
today my friend you got to set your
audio device to the appropriate one
and Tyrone Last Chance what is going on
my friend what's on your mind today
hello can you hear me yes now I can hear
you Tyrone what's going on
okay so like things in Ohio they're
getting real bad in here and I'm
wondering like a dentist wins what you
think is next
what is the gameplay
if DeSantis becomes president of the
United States you're saying
yes
well that was we're skipping ahead I
mean first he's got to become the
nominee you know your question depends
on what exactly is happening in January
of 2025 when a hypothetical DeSantis
presidency would start like what's on
your mind what specifically is getting
bad in Ohio that you're worried about
oh I mean just the name itself it's
already kind of bad but um you know just
like a
it seems like dystopian future would be
most ideal if uh distance became
president
I'm just wondering like what's the
direction of the country if he doesn't
well it's going to continue in this sort
of like modern I think what we're
calling it is reactionary populist uh
Direction and it's not going to be about
policy it's not going to be about
helping people it's not going to be
about improving the country it's going
to be about culture War issues and
reactionary populism and some
authoritarianism sprinkled in and
unfortunately DeSantis is arguably more
dangerous than Trump because he's less
incompetent but let's you know let's
first deal with the primaries I would
say just to not get ahead of ourselves
and we've got local elections coming up
in 2023 so there's still a lot of work
to do before we get to that let's let
Republicans have their primary first
then we'll worry about DeSantis
Tyrone all right Tyrone thank you very
much for the call an important question
let's go oh I don't know let's go to our
friend Eduardo from Brazil
hey David hey how are you um
I'm good how are you doing uh Mazel Tov
and Argentina by the way thank you very
very exciting
yeah very exciting uh so I have a one
question for you sure uh we're about to
go to transfer power here in Brazil to
the president on the first yes uh
Tallulah and uh but something has always
been bothering me like uh
before you know the the sort of denying
of elections results has always been
kind of a a third world country kind of
fair you know and um
and then Trump kind of pulled that into
his Playbook uh for you with a big lie
and everything
um so I guess my question to you is uh
did Trump kind of legitimize that for
like develop like like for like First
World countries or is it just becoming
kind of this oroboros where they just
kind of like created their own Playbook
according to
you know sort of what usually happened
in sort of underdeveloped countries no I
think Trump absolutely
legitimized questioning the election
results whereas you're right I mean you
know to say that it was the sort of
baileywick of third world countries
maybe it's sort of like to more accurate
to say or maybe more precise that
questioning election results
really just makes your country look bad
more than anything else but Trump
figured out a way to do it where at
least among his followers because he
kind of couched it as well it was
Democrats running elections and when it
was Republicans running elections it was
the Democrats doing the voter fraud and
and or it was Democratic judges but when
it was Trump appointed judges then it
was like the county commissioner you
know what it was just like a special
pleading no matter what he figured out a
way to do it where his followers can say
with a straight face we believe it was
rigged without out realizing what that
would suggest about the United States
and I do think that it's being copied in
other countries as you're pointed at
pointing out
it's uh it's kind of discerning because
you know
um the fact that
it's I mean I hate to say it but it's
kind of successful in in some ways
should perform Yeah by you saying it
like a lot of people you know do the
cult of personality or like the men can
do no wrong so if he says something it's
gospel you know now in Brazil are the
bolsonaro supporters saying it was
stolen from him he really won
well technically he conceited but his
followers have him like I mean I I've
I've been in Brazil for about two weeks
now yeah and uh yeah it it's there's a
very sort of uneasy feeling uh for
January 1st because there are still
picket lines they still
come out you know with with the shirt
like uh it's it's almost confusing
because every time you see like a car
with the Brazilian flag sticking out you
that automatically goes that that's a
like a bolsonaro follower yeah but it's
confusing with the World Cup because you
don't know if it's a World Cup kind of
like flag but he's Brazil left uh the
World Cup yeah so the the
there is a little feeling of an ease
here uh see seeing what happens because
a lot of people haven't accepted it even
though he has conceded understand
understand yeah I mean listen I I don't
know about in other countries but I
think in the U.S Republicans saying if
they lost that it was rigged is going to
be with us for at least another election
cycle
no it's the new normal which is is
worrisome for me because uh it's it's
become kind of part of the Playbook and
uh yeah I just wanted to run it by
because it's like the the
legitimization of of
um you know denying an election result
and unfortunately kind of Fairly
successfully done by Trump
um is is scary because it's just kind of
like again crosses the Rubicon that I
don't think it will be hard to come back
from it's extremely scary you're
absolutely right Eduardo thank you for
the call
thank you David take care all right
there goes Eduardo from Brazil let's go
next to Brian from Ireland Brian welcome
to the program what's on your mind today
hey David how are you okay yeah I'm
doing well yeah yeah I'm doing well
thanks very much
um
just a couple of small questions today
um
when Trump uh teased that announcement
and
you know it turned out to just be those
trading cards I I don't know I was I was
a bit you know it the whole thing has
been ridiculous for the last number of
years but yes I didn't think it would go
to this stage so that was a new low in
your mind the digital trading cards I I
just
I don't know in any of my wildest dreams
I didn't think that's what the
announcement was going to be right I
didn't know yeah but uh just one like
what do you think here what what do you
think could be the next um
bottom of the barrel that we find like
what could be the next just you know
just Wireless possible imagination thing
um in the world of trump what honestly I
don't know is it is it Trump trump is it
Trump doing uh some kind of celebrity
boxing match I I honestly I have no clue
I have no idea because
every time there's a new low and we say
it can't possibly get any worse than
this then there's another new low is it
Trump doing infomercials for some kind
of uh rotisserie cooking device like Ron
popeil's you know uh whatever it was
called I I genuinely don't know Brian
you could tell me anything and I would
say it's possible that that will be the
next thing
yeah it's a
it's increasingly funny to imagine you
know if it got into a a coma back in I
don't know 2014 or whatever if someone
was waking up now just or where do I
start explaining it would be completely
unbelievable no you're absolutely right
and and part of that I think is there's
an important lesson in there which is
even all of us in 2017 in January 2017
when Trump was inaugurated I think if we
had been told here's what it will be
like in 2022 most of us would not have
believed it
yeah 100 and now it is what it is you
know in Ireland are people just making
fun of trump like is he a laughing stock
um I certainly he was for a long time I
think you know since
um he left office and I guess left
Twitter Etc he's been
talked about a bit less but uh you know
I I follow he has colleagues closer to
most people so I'm still interested but
yeah I think like most of my family
wouldn't know much these days but what
he's up to interesting it's probably for
the best to be honest
probably
um just one or a quick thing
um on the World Cup briefly while we can
still talk about that quickly but uh
what um did you make of the Argentina
goalkeepers kind of Mind Games in the
penalty shootout do you think that was a
effective strategy do you think that
came into play or is it being when you
say mind games What specifically are you
referring to
well those I can't remember which of the
French
um takers it was whether it was their
the first one that missed or not but um
the the goalkeeper Martinez had the ball
in his hand and looked like he was going
to give it to the French guy but then
actually threw it away and made him walk
after it you know things like that oh I
didn't notice that that's interesting I
mean listen that's pretty funny my view
on all this stuff it's sort of like this
controversy about Chess Grand Master and
friend of the show Hikaru Nakamura
stalling in order to take advantage of a
rule related to how the match clock
relates to the game clock it's sort of
like if it's not against the rules you
figure out what to do to win and I don't
know if throwing the ball I I just I
don't have much of a feeling on it one
way or the other you know
yeah not fair enough yeah no I I I'm not
certainly not accusing them breaking
rules or anything I just thought it was
an interesting uh that he was getting
into the French player's head and it
seemed to work to a degree so Hey listen
real quick a friend of mine when he was
in Ireland went on a potato walking food
tour where it sounds like a joke but he
would stop at they would stop at
different places with a local guide each
Place preparing potatoes in dramatically
different ways is is that a complete
tourist trap or is that actually
something like locally interesting
culinarily in in Ireland
well I haven't heard of that specific
attraction but to be honest to be
perfectly honest with you even though it
is a stereotype I I would still uh go on
that tour let those sound I love
potatoes I mean it sounds pretty good to
me yeah I have to say if you're if
you're at a wedding here in Ireland I'll
finish up with this but if you're a
guest at a wedding
um and it's kind of food being served
family style you know all dishes Etc
yeah there'll be there will be three
different types of potato at least you
know they'll be mashed they're being um
dolphin oils whatever you know there's
going to be a few different options I
like that that's it all right well I
gotta get over there and try some of
these potatoes I have to tell you
please do all right good to talk to you
later all right Brian from Ireland thank
you so much for the call very much
appreciate it let's go to Jill from
Burbank California Jill welcome to the
program what is on your mind today
hey David how you doing I'm doing well
okay uh well big fan and uh just have
many questions I have written them down
but I'm just gonna do two of them
um I don't know whenever we watch one of
those Trump trump rallies at the end he
says this country doesn't belong to them
this country belongs to you yes isn't
that a fascist like that's the biggest
dagger in like America's throat saying
this country basically belongs to you
guys only what America is is all about
uh you know everybody else and we love
our neighbors like well if you if you
question them about it they would say
what Trump means is this is the country
of the people not not literally just the
people at the Trump rally it's just the
country of the people is what they say
is meant by it
well to me how it sounds it's those
people and not the other people totally
fair I'm just telling you like if you
confronted them with it this is what
they would say
I I I mean they they say a lot of a lot
of things that like that are have put
basically that made them uh Hypocrites
yes like the one I saw from yesterday
the lady was driving a uh SUV with an uh
hashtag fjb in the back yep but she had
like all the Christmas stuff
around it Christmas stands for like love
you know and everything like from uh you
know sharing and caring and all like
that's what Christmas is and she but I
mean how can she be Evangelical or a
Christian true Christian and
also put in you know FJ being in the
back of the car that really blew my mind
I'm with you that hypocrisy is is quite
stunning but it is prevalent and it is
uh it's like its own virus in the United
States
right uh can I can I do one more
question this this is going to be
actually a question all right
those were just statements it's better
when people just get right to questions
going forward but I'll I'll allow it's
got to be real quick though I got a lot
of people holding
okay uh so if you remember Trump said
oranges of the investigation and he said
it like many many times and then he
explained it as origin like oh the
beginning
Beginnings so that was
from many many many many many uh
examples the other one was during the
rally he said oh Mark Zuckerberg last
week came to the White House and he was
out of you you know yeah it was like
years after he left the Oval Office yeah
right so is he done did in your in your
uh in your head is is he done done uh
from a mental standpoint listen I don't
know I don't know because on the one
hand Trump does remember things and can
sometimes be coherent but he just like
glitches so much and I I I I really
don't know what's going on with Trump
cognitively I'm not sure I'm not really
in a position to say it's very strange
and that's what our position has been
it's bizarre and as he just loses his
train of thought and that type of thing
but ultimately I don't know what's going
on question probably more for a
neurologist
right okay maybe we should have a
neurologist on on your show up to go
over Jill I will look into it I
appreciate the call thank you all right
thank you all right let's uh a lot going
on there a lot lot going on there let's
go uh actually you know what let's let's
take a very quick break if you're
holding don't hang up because we're
going back to the phones but we're going
to take a very brief break reset let
emotions simmer and then we'll hear from
some more people in a moment
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
let's go back to the phones and by
phones I mean Discord we're using
digital phones at this point
davidpackman.com Discord is the place to
go let's go to Thai from Connecticut Ty
what is going on
uh hey David
um I just wanted to
kind of give my uh the two cents on like
I think it was a re-upload you did
um
about Obama the comments that he had
about like the too far left in the work
left and this and that and
I just I really
I really struggled with that one because
in my opinion I think uh Obama is
probably more
um
responsibility I'm still here yeah it's
probably more responsible for I think
I think the disillusionment of a lot of
activists and maybe the rise of wokism
uh then
um I mean any other phenomenon I can
think of certainly that was how I was
effective being disappointed by
um
the lack of
um
Progressive uh ideals and policy I mean
this whole Avenue was written in by
Citigroup you know he bailed out
Banks and not the homeowners he
continued torture he I think I think
more than anything any single policy
issue that really drives me insane is
that I think that he is somewhat
responsible for
the rise of trump
I'm I think here's the here's why I
struggle with let's just pick one thing
because you're mentioning you're
mentioning a lot and I don't know if a
question is coming so let me just
comment on one aspect of that it's not
reading it's not really a question it's
not it's just me being displeased yeah
so listen I mean here's the thing the
entire like Obama led to Trump sort of
thing the reason I find that to be
really tough is one perspective is Obama
led to Trump by not being as Progressive
as he pretended he was going to be which
disillusioned people which caused some
people to say I'm not going out to vote
for Hillary so let it be Trump if that's
the alternate okay so like that's one
perspective the other perspective is
Obama by being half black allowed Trump
to coalesce nativists xenophobes
starting with the birth certificate
thing moving into the Mexican rapist
thing and so like that's a different way
in which you could say Obama led to
Trump but it's just Obama's identity
it's nothing he can control so I don't
know I think there's a mix of stuff that
went on can I just add one little quick
thing to that very last point because I
wanted to touch on that yeah sure is
that I find him
responsible for a lot of that because in
in the face of that that
virulent gross racism that was festering
and targeted at him I mean the reason
why Donald Trump even became a popular
political figure in this modern era was
because he was on Fox News every other
month talking about how Obama was wasn't
a you know American because he was black
and and Oppa and here's my frustration
with kind of like where you're going
with Obama's saying is that was the
moment we needed the wokism that was the
moment that we needed him to call that a
spade for a spade and not play around
with it and yoke with it like it was
something funny and to bring attention
to it and to have the political
historical uh foresight and uh
retrospective to understand what it is
that you're placating instead of having
beer Summits with police who murder
innocent black people and yeah I don't I
don't I think I get what you're going I
don't know that my view on it is so
black and white I think you can have the
beer Summit to send one signal and then
you can take seriously the birth
certificate thing and then you can joke
about it at the White House
correspondence dinner I don't know to
say those are the reason that that I I
struggle with that but let me give it
some more thought I'm glad you've had
your opportunity to uh to to make your
point and I hope to hear from you again
okay thank you take care and just as a
reminder please get right to your
question because we do have a lot of
people that want to get on and I think
as a general thing people will be
um appreciative of that uh and that's an
important thing let's go to Steve from
the San Francisco Bay Area Steve welcome
to the program what's on your mind today
hey Dave cool to talk to you again thank
you
um
I I agree with Jill about the uh fjb
stickers on the Christian cars like I'm
a Christian you know that and that's
just not cool anyways on my question yep
um so I was talking to a co-worker the
other day about like how much money
would it take for you to just quit your
job retire and just pursue whatever you
wanted to pursue and you don't have to
like work for money
um like my my number would be like five
to ten million I guess but that's
arbitrary it's in for each person what
would you don't have to share what your
number would be but what would you do if
like money wasn't a factor for you would
you continue doing this show would you
do something else yeah I'm doing it now
I mean that's the amazing I'm doing what
I want to be doing and it's great that
it's worked out to be you know a
business that functions but I'm I'm
doing the thing I want to be doing
that's great yeah and it's not just
money that's pretty sweet I mean I guess
maybe I'd consider going and like
selling athletic shoes or something like
that but I kind of like what I'm doing
cool what do you do in your free time
for hobby hobbies and like just personal
growth this is quite a call I I read I
travel I go to the gym I bike and run
you know I hang out with my baby
daughter which takes up a lot of time a
lot a lot of time if you want to if you
want to figure out uh you know how to
really optimize your time have a have a
baby around
um what else what are my other Hobbies I
don't know making prank phone calls to
other political shows oh damn I'm not
supposed to say that
um no I don't know I mean you know it's
all it's all pretty basic
cool yeah I just wanted to ask an
atypical question more about your
personal uh opinions on some
non-political things so that's all but
that thanks for taking Michael what show
are you watching right now
I'm not watching anything I'm just
waiting in the lobby getting ready to go
to work no I don't mean literally right
now I'm just saying is there a TV show
right now that you're watching oh I'm
sorry
uh ah man a show I'm I mean I've uh
there's a lot out there I'm I really was
in the rings of power while that was on
and I binged the crap out of that
haven't heard of that all right all
right well thank you for the call I
appreciate it oh thanks man all right
there we go I'll have to check I'll have
to check out that show it sounds sounds
compelling to some degree all right
let's go to Jorge from South Florida I
will soon be in South Florida and it's
going to be pretty explosive I think
hortica
hey David how's it going it's going well
wonderful so I'm gonna make it really
quick because I know you want a good
question so I got two questions please
one is a ideological question that I
want to ask see if you can tag a little
bit on I could I've got people here in
South Florida talk about the whole
difference between nationalism and
patriotism yep and I've come to the
conclusion that it's very similar but
it's very different at the same time
okay what's your take on that
uh I don't know that I sorry did I cut
you off there
no no I'm sorry I'm sorry I asked
afterwards sorry I'm not totally sure I
understand the question
so I think that I was raised in Spain
you think that you were raised in Spain
or you were raised in Spain
sorry I was raised in Spain okay I think
in my idea that the difference would be
nationalism being something that the
government tells you you gotta love the
country opposed to patriotism being you
love the country because you love where
you live does that make sense yeah we
feel we did like a patriotism versus
nationalism thing
um you know here's the thing there I
have two thoughts on this one thought is
this is a meaningful distinction and
there's something about
patriotism is not
condescending or discriminatory or
oppressive whereas nationalism can be
right that's like one view I guess the
other view would be we're really just
kind of arguing about semantics and both
and and patriotism can be just as toxic
as nationalism depending on what you
mean by it I don't know I I'm not really
sure to be totally honest I do think I
do think
for example in Argentina
one of the things a lot of argentinians
will mention to me when they come to the
US is there's just so many American
flags out like all the time and it's
weird for two reasons it's weird on the
one hand because it does feel more
nationalistic than patriotic but also it
also loses meaning when the flags are
out all the time we're like in Argentina
people don't just tend to display flags
all the time but like there's a flag day
and people display flags that day it
seems more meaningful because it's a
specific day but also in Argentina the
people displaying the flags
aren't more likely to be the Nationalist
types like in the U.S so so I do think
there's definitely a difference in the
U.S when it comes to Flags nationalism
and patriotism I just don't know that I
would focus on the difference between
nationalism and patriotism
that makes sense thank you
um that makes sense my other question
would be
as an Argentinian I gotta bet my wife on
this one do you eat Asados or no yes I
do yeah oh okay I I just had a feeling
that you were more uh by what you
publicize more like plant-based diet so
I thought maybe you weren't into Asados
okay I don't eat a lot of red meat but
when I go to Argentina you know and and
of course yes absolutely yeah oh okay
thank you David uh did you win the bet
or lose it
I lost it you lost it all right well I
apologize all right according from South
Florida very very good lost to bed and
we can all uh sort of explore explore
that further let's go to it's either
Ally or Ali from Finland welcome to the
program
Ali Ali uh so so uh who do you want to
win in 2024 and who do you think will
win in 2024 you're talking about the
presidential race yes it depends who
runs I don't know who's I don't know
who's who the candidates are going to be
at
Glory who do you want to be the
president well I there's people I think
would be good presidents that I don't
even know if they're thinking of running
uh I think Jamie Raskin would be a great
president and I've mentioned to that to
him when I had him on the show uh I
think Pete boot Edge would be a great
president
um John ossoff probably lacks The
Experience so far but uh John ossoff is
interesting Stacy Abrams is brilliant
and you know I think would be a very
interesting president
um but you know a lot of this stuff is
Pie in the Sky it's like would George
Clooney make a good mayor of La I mean
maybe but I don't know that he has any
interest in running I I it's hard
because I I'm maybe too pragmatic or
let's let's see who runs you know get
honestly I think Gavin Newsom would be a
good president he's not the most
Progressive but he's striking the right
tone when it comes to dealing with
Republicans I think there's lots of
interesting people I just don't know if
any of them are going to run
right okay so the second question uh
what do you think are the greatest
priority goals for the country and how
would you prioritize achieving those
well I mean that we need I need 10 hours
really but zooming out I think the most
important issues for the country to deal
with that will trickle down and affect
other issues include campaign campaign
finance and how politics is financed
how elections are run where I would like
to get off of the electoral college
system and I would like to get off of
first past the post and we've talked
about do you do that via uh the national
popular vote interstate compact I mean
each of these topics is hours of
discussion I think dealing with climate
change because if you're in a climate
crisis you can't be an activist for any
issue
um and then probably number four getting
Health Care to everyone because if
you're sick and can't get care you're
also Limited in your ability to be an
activist to work to earn a living Etc so
I would say those are the four top
issues
right so so do you think like it's
better to campaign for the president or
Congress or
overall or what was the best way you're
saying as a candidate or as a voter
as a voter yes oh I think you can do all
of the above I mean listen you can phone
bank for multiple candidates you can
donate to multiple candidates I think
that it's it's not about more or less
important it's your your Congress person
and your senator
deal with different things than your
mayor and City councilor and the
president so I I mean in an Ideal World
people would be involved in all of them
and not all of those elections are at
the same time either
right okay that was all my questions all
right uh Ali from Finland how is Finland
these days
uh snowy snowy so okay do you live in
where do you live Helsinki
uh
what's that like is it a large city town
uh it's the third largest I think
baseball population what's the
population
uh you're putting me on the spot I think
300 000. oh okay very interesting and is
it a place where what when does the sun
set at this time of year
oh it's like four o'clock oh all right
well that's not that crazy no shot by
like 10 and goes down like four so six
hours maybe oh the sun doesn't come up
until 10. yeah oh is that is that rough
yeah oh interesting interesting wow wow
yeah I don't know that I would deal well
with that well listen I really
appreciate the call it's been been great
hearing from you
sure you too all right there we go uh
folks we heard from all over the world
we went to Ireland we went to Finland we
went where else did we go we went
everywhere
um that's it for calls today I will take
calls again and hope to speak to you
soon we'll take a quick break and be
right back
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show let's get
to the mailbag for the week you can
email info davidpackman.com if you have
something to say hopefully
um it doesn't have to be positive but
maybe at least uh thought provoking in
some way or uh interesting or I don't
know something up Dottie wrote in to me
and this one came in via Facebook and
Dottie said you're an idiot first word
is already wrong as you know almost a
requirement in these emails that you use
the wrong your or you're an idiot you
don't talk about our president that way
president Trump is our president and he
said exactly what he should have said
those people that are in jail are not
criminals they're innocent people that
were put there just to show face in the
Democratic party so don't talk about
President Trump he's exactly right and
he's not confused about anything you're
the one that's confused examine your own
mind open up your mind and realize what
you're saying he's a smart ass and the
best president we've ever had
one sentence
I guess no punctuation
complete cult
commitment
to Donald Trump and mega trumpism
this is someone who will vote Trump in
2024. so if we're thinking about what is
the math what is the what is the
constituency that takes Trump down
it probably doesn't include Dottie
and that's okay that constituency may
still exist but
this is what I don't even know where
we're going this is what we're up
against and it's really really scary
Michael wrote In
with a slightly more grammatically
correct but still factually vapid
uh statement called leftist hypocrisy
Michael wrote the sixth January I'm
sorry the January 6 quote rioters did
not break the law they were allowed in
even invited by Capital police as seen
on video
they are Innocent but you don't care
because you're a demo rat wrong you're
suffering tedious and happy to jail
political opponents not me you must have
my politics mixed up with someone else's
you never called for antifa Arrested
even though they did millions in damage
way more than the protesters on January
6 also people died in the antifa riots
the only death at the Capitol was Ashley
Babbitt killed by Rogue cop yet you
don't want him jailed just walk free
like nothing you are a hypocrite and
it's clear to anyone who isn't a demo
rap
so this is crazy
uh but a few important points I think to
mention
I have never said
if someone committed a crime
don't prosecute them I have never said
that I have always said
if there were crimes committed during an
antifa demonstration or a black lives
matter demonstration no matter who did
it whether it was a member of antifa to
the extent that there's membership if it
was a part of be whoever
if there is evidence that a crime was
committed charge the person I don't care
about the affiliation I also know
that the 700 defendants from the Trump
riots are obviously not innocent and in
fact courts and juries have adjudicated
them guilty in already dozens if not
hundreds I don't know where we are in
the process of all those cases I am not
happy to jail political opponents in
fact I'm against it
I I don't believe in jailing people
because we have different politics I do
believe that if you want to make an
argument that pre-trial detention in
this country is a problem by the way
it's an argument I've been making for a
decade you are the one who has to be
consistent because all of these right
Wingers only now care about pre-trial
detention for defendants they never
cared about it before they never cared
about it when it was people with whom
they disagreed politically so they are
the Hypocrites not me uh better
marketing Spencer wrote in about the
left and better marketing and says David
do you think the left needs to Market
and message their policies better
Medicare for all doesn't seem to be
driving people to the polls remember
more people supported gay marriage once
it was called marriage equality
and more people supported gun control
once it was called ending gun violence
Medicare for all seems like a government
program like a welfare giveaway maybe
call it guaranteed health care or
something similar Beth Spencer so
there's two questions here the first is
about the best name for a Health Care
System where everybody has coverage
I I quite frankly don't care what you
call it I'm totally open to the idea
that Medicare for all may not be the
best term
I don't know about guaranteed Health
Care who's guaranteeing it I don't know
but just focus group it let's figure out
what the right term is does the left
need to better market and frame a
thousand percent and I've talked about
this so many times before the left loses
so much on framing we've talked about
pro-life we've talked about tax relief
we've talked about uh you know what
medical freedom but used in a completely
dishonest way uh yeah there are so many
examples the left does need help on that
it seems like a worthwhile thing to uh
to put some money into quite frankly
Fritz wrote in and Fritz is happy
because there's finally a progressive
voice on the radio Fritz writes hello Mr
Pacman and crew I grew up and still live
in rural Indiana I currently live in
Goshen Indiana which is a micro City
I've been to Goshen radio is still a
major part of Rural Life in Indiana it's
free and people spend a lot of time in
their vehicles yes we have public radio
and it's okay but there's so little
testosterone on the public stations in
comparison to the bombastic crap on the
right that leftists are just saying
really arguments seem weak or
unenthusiastic please note I am not
saying you're some sort of Super Macho
Man for Progressive values Fritz I don't
think anyone thinks you're saying I'm
some kind of Macho Man I don't know that
that's necessarily a correction that was
necessary uh but at least you're willing
to be argumentative and quite frankly it
works in this area you're willing to
engage with them and where they are on
the radio in rural in Indiana it will
make a difference or at least it will
stir the pot a bit thanks again Fritz
Fritz thank you uh we you know we do the
radio show some people may or may not
know this
we don't make any money from the
syndicated radio show and I'm not saying
this like oh I have tears in my eyes
even though I'm a big strong guy I'm
just saying we've decided even though we
don't monetize radio like our income
comes from the online podcast YouTube
Etc
we produce the radio show at our expense
it's a loss okay it's like a trump
business it's a loss
um because we think it's worth being on
in a lot of these rural places where
there are very few options for
non-right-wing or religious uh radio so
we're doing it and uh we're gonna
continue to do it Irv Rodin Irv says
David it always amazes me when right
Wingers call you a communist insultingly
yet are devotees of Tucker Carlson and
the Fox News cabal who idolize the most
communist country and its leader Putin
in fact so much so that they are
featured in virtually all of Putin's
propaganda campaigns aren't they the
Communists
they will never accept this analysis
ever ever ever
they will say
uh it's not about defending communism
it's about the left has a vendetta
against Russia for no reason or what
they will squirrel their ways out of it
but it is interesting that many of the
people that Trump was most impressed by
are from countries that don't exactly
have market economies Russia North Korea
we've seen it all uh good luck
convincing them Sam wrote in about the
death penalty and says David I have to
disagree with your views regarding the
death penalty it is definitely true that
many people have been convicted
incorrectly where the evidence is
circumstantial no death penalty is
warranted but when you have mass murder
I assume they mean Mass murderers like
John Gacy Jeffrey Dahmer and mass School
shooters like Nicholas Cruz where there
is no contradictory evidence there
should be executions these people serve
no function and are of no value to
society to the dismay of the victim's
families Nicholas Cruz was just recently
sentenced for Life perhaps if your
daughter had been one of his victims you
would have a different point of view
this is so important
Sam is not wrong
if my daughter had been a victim of one
of these school shootings
I might have a different point of view
but that would be out of a desire for
Revenge
and we shouldn't have a justice system
based on Revenge so
Sam is actually making my point
which is that is not a good
justification for the death penalty the
fact that if I was in this situation I
might want revenge by saying kill them
it wouldn't make it any more right it
would just mean I want revenge so super
interesting and I think Sam not making
the strong point that Sam thinks he or
she is making a rod wrote in about Trump
sweating and says I believe that Trump
is sweating because he may be diagnosed
with ADHD which is treated with ritalin
and sweating as a possible side effect
this fits his profile well if it is true
that Trump is medicated for ADHD
that medication was not uh revealed in
the medical release about the
medications that Donald Trump takes now
would it be a big shock if Trump had
hidden elements of his health uh record
no it wouldn't because he put something
out claiming he's 6'3 and weighs 239
pounds and we all know that that's not
true uh but as far as the record is
concerned Trump is not on uh Ritalin and
not being treated for ADHD write in info
davidpackman.com if you have something
to say uh questions or welcome comments
are welcome demands for Corrections when
they are accurate are welcome as well we
will uh see you on today's bonus show
we're off Monday in observance of the
Christmas holiday uh and we will be back
on Tuesday we'll see everybody then or
on the bonus
foreign
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors please donate to
give directly the non-profit letting you
send cash directly to the world's
poorest families when you donate to give
directly.org Pacman a generous donor
will match your donations up to fifteen
thousand dollars makes a perfect holiday
gift help us reach fifteen thousand
dollars by the end of the year using the
link below